-Hey, everybody. Welcome to
an all-new "Tonight Show."
We're here in New York City.
It's a big nor'easter in 2021.
And if you can see, the streets
are basically empty.
I mean, the city
is kind of shut down right now.
But we are going to do
a brand-new show for you guys
because we're here.
But if this were
pre-pandemic times,
we would have to do the show
with no audience anyway.
So with that in mind,
this might be the first normal
show we've done in 10 months.
So let's do it!
Welcome to "The Tonight Show"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-From Rockefeller Center
in the heart of New York City,
it's "The Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon."
Tonight, join Jimmy
and his guests --
Musical guest Remi Wolf,
and featuring
the legendary Roots crew.
And now here he is,
Jimmy Fallon.
♪♪
-Thank you very much!
Hello! Welcome! Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you very much, everybody.
Hello, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Thank you for watching at home.
I appreciate it.
Well, guys, the first nor'easter
of 2021 began yesterday
and continued all day today,
just blasting
the Northeast with snow.
Here in New York, a state
of emergency was declared.
I'm not really sure
that was necessary.
Since last March,
our resting status
has pretty much been
state of emergency, but --
That's right, New York City
got nearly 2 feet of snow.
All day, New Yorkers
were frantically shoveling
until they remembered
there's nowhere to go.
But what a crazy storm
it's been so far --
freezing temperatures, high
winds, multiple feet of snow.
Today, even the anti-maskers
were like, "Okay, give me one.
Just -- Here --"
The weather is so bad,
tomorrow, Punxsutawney Phil
is gonna pop out of his little
groundhog Airbnb and be like,
"What do you think
I'm predicting?
Go bother Sam Champion
with this crap."
Seriously, the weather
was so brutal,
even Joe Biden
spent the day at Mar-A-Lago.
[ Laughter, groaning ]
That's right.
The East Coast is being rocked
by a blizzard right now.
In New York, it is so cold --
-How cold is it?
-It's so cold,
I saw a subway rat
wearing a pair
of Bernie mittens.
It is so cold.
-How cold is it?
-It's so cold,
Pfizer and Moderna
are storing their vaccines
outside on Fifth Avenue.
I mean, it is cold.
-How cold is it?
-It's so cold, the New Year's
Eve ball went back up.
It is so cold.
-No, Jimmy, stop.
-What is it, Roots?
-When we say, "How cold is it?"
we mean it literally.
We actually want to know
how cold it is.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, it's like 35 degrees.
-Thank you.
[ Applause ]
-But the snowstorm
isn't bad news for everyone.
Take a look at how one of
the pandas at the National Zoo
was handling it.
Yeah, that panda either loves
the snow or is incredibly drunk.
30 seconds after this video,
the panda threw up bamboo
for five straight minutes.
They don't show that.
Meanwhile, here in New York,
kids got some pretty mixed news
about schools this morning.
Listen to this.
-New York City schools
are closed.
However, students are required
to learn remotely today.
-Yeah, in the split-second
between hearing "schools closed"
and "remote learning,"
every teacher finished
a bottle of wine.
Yeah.
Come on. They made them
go to school on a snow day?
Seriously, those Zoom rooms
must've looked like
a pissed-off
"Brady Bunch" opening.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, today in Washington,
President Biden
met with 10 Republican senators
about their COVID relief plan.
They want about
$600 billion in aid,
while Democrats want
$1.9 trillion.
Yeah, the meeting got heated.
According to the transcript,
Biden shouted 12 "come on, mans"
and 19 "gimme a breaks."
Well, this isn't good. The
impeachment trial is next week,
and Trump's legal team
doesn't seem ready. Watch this.
-With just days to go until
his second impeachment trial,
all five
of the impeachment lawyers
expected to represent
former president Donald Trump
have quit, splitting over
a disagreement in strategy.
-Trump was furious.
Not that they quit -- that he
couldn't fire them on Twitter.
Yeah, Trump and his lawyers
disagreed on strategy.
Apparently, Trump got upset
when they wanted to have one.
But there's good news for Trump,
because after he lost
five lawyers,
he was able to replace them
with two new ones.
Can we hear a little bit
about them?
-Donald Trump has picked
two new attorneys,
David Schoen and Bruce Castor.
-David Schoen was consulting
with Jeffrey Epstein
before his death.
Bruce Castor, most notably,
deciding not to go ahead
with the prosecution
against Bill Cosby in 2005.
[ Laughter ]
-What? Was the guy who defended
Saddam Hussein not available?
I mean --
[ Laughter, applause ]
Even Rudy Giuliani thought,
"You're going with these guys?"
Listen to this. If you're still
traveling during the pandemic,
maybe this will give you
something else to think about.
-According to a safety
reporting system run by NASA,
the rise of in-flight errors
during commercial flights
is being blamed on pilots being
rusty because of the pandemic.
-Don't worry.
It's just like riding a bike
30,000 feet above the ground.
[ Laughter ]
It's not good when you hear
a pilot walk into the cockpit
and go, "Oh, boy."
[ Laughter ]
"There's buttons on the
ceilings, too?" [ Babbles ]
Some business news.
I saw that this month,
Dunkin' Donuts is offering
free coffee every Monday.
Well, in honor of that, we'd
like to give a little shout-out
to their most loyal customer
in history.
♪♪
-♪ Yeah ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's my dude.
I read about
a woman in Minnesota
who wanted to show her daughter
her wedding dress
but had an interesting surprise.
Check this out.
-A Minnesota woman is on a quest
to find her wedding gown.
Wendy Taylor pulled out the box
she paid to have professionally
packaged 14 years ago,
but she was was shocked to find
her gown had been swapped
with someone else's.
-Yeah. Then she opened
the frozen wedding cake
in the freezer
and discovered it was a burrito.
The woman was like,
"This can't be my wedding dress
because it doesn't
fit me at all."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
I heard about a man in Idaho
who just won the lottery
for the sixth time.
Yeah, this last jackpot
was $250,000.
And with the money,
he plans to buy Idaho.
Guys, I am so psyched that
Bryan Cranston is here tonight.
We love Bryan Cranston.
We were actually texting
over the weekend,
and it turns out that we're both
obsessed with fancy soaps.
Yeah, here, check this out.
♪♪
-♪ Fancy soaps in a fancy dish ♪
♪ One's a seashell,
one's a fish ♪
♪ One soap's purple,
one soap's teal ♪
♪ One soap's made
with dry oatmeal ♪
-♪ Lavender, lemongrass,
lily, lilac ♪
♪ This one comes
in a drawstring sack ♪
♪ Tiny soaps, vanilla and plum ♪
-♪ Put them out
when company comes ♪
-♪ Soaps were made
to make you cleaner ♪
-♪ This one's citrus,
that's verbena ♪
-♪ Heart-shaped soaps
for a love that's true ♪
-♪ Crystal soap
you can see right through ♪
♪ Dish, terrine, platter, tray ♪
♪ Fancy soaps go on display ♪
-♪ Pine tree soap
to put in your pocket ♪
-♪ Goat milk soap
from the farmer's market ♪
-♪ Tea time soap
with chamomile ♪
-♪ Shea butter soap
for a softer feel ♪
-♪ Fruity soaps
smell like fruit snacks ♪
-♪ Lava soap
that's entirely black ♪
-♪ When a friend stops by
whether ready or not ♪
♪ No liquid soap
for a two-pump shot ♪
♪ Not potpourri
nor candlesticks ♪
♪ Just fancy soaps
in a fancy dish ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My thanks to Bryan Cranston!